ILYA GRIGORIK: Hello everyone,
and welcome to our Make the
Web Fast series on Google
Developers Live.
Today, we're going to talk about
an awesome new image
format called WebP, and with
us today, we have Stephen
Konig from the WebP team.
STEPHEN KONIG: Great.
Thanks, Ilya.
It's great to be here and update
all of you on what
we've been working with WebP
and hopefully convince you
that it's a great alternative.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So speaking of
convincing, let's get this
right off the bat, right?
I'm a busy person.
I'm a developer, I
got features to
build, code to write.
Images.
Why should I care about
images, first of all?
And second of all, I have a
buddy designer who's great.
He does awesome work,
and he tells me that
he optimizes images.
I'm not sure what he's using,
but I trust him.
So why do we care?
STEPHEN KONIG: Why do we care?
One of the reasons we care is
that images make up a huge
proportion of the amount of
bytes that we send in most web
pages, and I think we've got
some data to talk about that.
But if we're looking at ways of
making the web faster, it's
one of the most obvious things
we need to look at as far as
how we can optimize.
And in terms of image
optimization, there's lots of
different aspects of that, but
ultimately it comes down to
how we can produce
the smallest size
for the best quality.
And we think WebP offers some
unique advantages in that way,
and we think it plays an
important part in how people
use the web.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Interesting.
OK, so speaking of data, as
we were preparing for this
presentation, I checked some
data on the HTTP archive, and
I specifically looked at mobile
because mobile is an
exploding topic, traffic
going through the roof.
So this is data across a couple
thousand of the most
popular mobile sites.
And when I look at the overall
size of the page, first of
all, an average page is
about 700 kilobytes.
So it's actually a little bit
less than a desktop version,
which is good news.
But then, this number
actually shocked me.
When I look at the breakdown
between the different content
types, images are basically 70%
of the data on the wire.
STEPHEN KONIG: That's
pretty typical.
It's actually a little bit
higher on mobile than what we
see on desktop, but the fact
that it's the single largest
component of the page size is
very consistent with what we
see across desktop as well.
The other thing I noticed for
mobile, in addition to just
the raw bandwidth we're
consuming, typically users are
more bandwidth constrained on
mobile than they are on
desktop, and in some cases
having to pay for that.
So think about it from the
perspective of what you're
asking your users to pay when
you're designing your web
pages and images are such
an important and sizable
component of that.
ILYA GRIGORIK: I would love
for my browser to have a
sidebar on the side saying,
you've paid this much to
download this page.
STEPHEN KONIG: How
much you spent.
Exactly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: We should build
an extension for that.
That would be awesome.
And then I guess the other thing
to point out, especially
in mobile today, it's become
a hiDPI world.
And in fact, it only recently
occurred to me that we really
need to shift the conversation
away from should I be doing
hiDPI towards basically
every device you
buy nowadays is hiDPI.
Certainly maybe a year ago, or
a year and a half ago, it was
still a novelty item, like you
had to pay extra to get your
retina experience
kind of thing.
And today, if you look across
the board, you're getting
hiDPI devices no matter what.
STEPHEN KONIG: Exactly.
They're definitely
proliferating, and I think as
users begin experience
these devices, they
don't want to go back.
So we're going to see increasing
demand on the part
of consumers for more
hiDPI devices.
And the unfortunate thing is
most images today are designed
for a low DPI environment.
So when you translate
those to hiDPI, they
don't look so good.
And so it's putting a lot of
pressure on publishers to
update their sites and their
images to look better on these
hiDPI devices.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And that's a
really hard one, right?
Because to your point earlier,
my bandwidth is not going to
up magically by four, or latency
decrease by four, but
all of a sudden, the images are
getting four times bigger.
STEPHEN KONIG: Exactly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And I think,
actually, the four is worth
explaining.
When we say hiDPI, we usually
mean twice the size of the
image, but you need to remember
that it's twice the
width and twice the height,
which means
four times the pixels.
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So if we just
take whatever we were doing
and apply it to hiDPI images,
we're going to get file sizes,
instead of 600 kilobytes
for mobile,
it'll be several megabytes.
STEPHEN KONIG: Exactly.
And that's just even at the
same quality level.
So if you're using a lossy
format like JPEG, in addition
to that, what you're probably
going to see is a demand for
higher quality images with your
compression artifacts.
So that in itself will
also play a part in
increasing the size.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So there's probably no magic
bullet to say we can have both
hiDPI and a lower file size, but
perhaps there's a middle
road somewhere in between.
STEPHEN KONIG: Exactly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Such that
it's not just a
4x across the board.
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And I guess the
other thing that I find when I
talk to a lot of developers is
just picking the right image
format is actually
a challenge.
STEPHEN KONIG: It is.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So as I mentioned
earlier, when I
talked to a lot of web
developers and designers, they
say, great, I took my image,
I optimized it.
I saved it as a JPEG or as a
PNG, and I ran it through some
tool that optimizes that format,
which is great except
that you're probably
optimizing the
wrong thing, right?
STEPHEN KONIG: Exactly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So picking the
right image format is actually
very tricky problem.
STEPHEN KONIG: It is.
You have JPEG, which is quite
common, but you have PNG for
lossless, you've got
GIFs for animation.
And unfortunately, we see still
some confusion among
some developers in terms of what
those different formats,
and how they should be used,
and what context
you should use them.
So we see things like people
taking JPEGs and then
recompressing them as PNGs.
So you have a nice, lossless
representation of your lossy
format, which really doesn't
help so much in the end.
But it does put you as a
developer in the position of
having to understand what are
the characteristics of the
different image formats?
When should I use one
over the other?
And how should I mix
and match those?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
And I should mention that this
is actually one of the core
optimizations that we have in
our Page Speed product, so Mod
PageSpeed, Nginx PageSpeed, and
PageSpeed service where we
take the image that you
provide us with,
whatever that may be--
JPEG or PNG--
and then we actually try to
transcode it into other
formats in the background.
And then we figure out that,
hey, this image file is
actually much better
compressed if we
use JPEG, for example.
So we don't assume anything
about your decisions.
And it sounds like WebP could
actually be the one to rule
them all, if you will?
STEPHEN KONIG: That's part of
our goal for WebP is finding a
way to encompass the different
kinds of attributes that you
want to see from your images,
and offering you one format
that you can use across the
board and to support those
different kinds of use cases.
So whether you want to do a
lossy format, whether you want
to do lossless, whether you want
to do animation, you can
do all those up with WebP, and
so now you don't have to face
this choice.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Awesome.
So maybe a little bit
about the history.
Were did it come from?
What is it?
STEPHEN KONIG: So we announced
WebP about two years ago.
It's actually derived from the
WebM video format, so it
derives from VP8 video codec.
So it's basically taking a key
frame from the VP8 video codec
and using that as an image
representation.
So it is fully open source,
royalty free.
All the source code is
out there, all the
libraries are out there.
It's free to use,
free to deploy.
No issues there.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
And actually, just
a quick tip.
Last week, we had a great
episode on WebM and some of
the future of WebM with the
VP9 work that the team is
doing at YouTube and
all the rest.
So if you're interested, I
really recommend just going
back in the History for GDL
and checking that out.
STEPHEN KONIG: So a little brief
history on the timeline.
So as I mentioned, we did an
initial release and launch of
that back in 2010, which
initially just had support for
lossy compression.
In October of 2011, we followed
that up with support
for color profiles
and XMP metadata.
Last year, we added lossless,
which was the support for PNG
type formats, as well
as transparency.
And in terms of what we're
working on, we've actually got
a couple things coming that
are really exciting.
You'll actually see a new
release coming out in about a
week or two that will
add support for
animation and metadata.
So that will replace
the GIF use case.
Longer term, we're looking at
ways of improving performance
on the encode and decode side,
so we're always looking at
optimizations we can do there.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And we're
actually going
to talk about that.
STEPHEN KONIG: We're going to
talk a little bit about that.
Better support for RN mobile.
So those platforms are supported
today, but there's
work we know we can do to
make them even faster.
And then in the future, we'll be
thinking about things like
adding support for layers, so
for 3D images, as well as high
color depth images.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So just before
the GDL, we were joking about
we have the hiDPI, and then
we're going to get to the 3D
images in high def.
STEPHEN KONIG: In high
def color depth.
Exactly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: This sounds
like a disaster from
performance.
It's going to be beautiful.
STEPHEN KONIG: It's going to be
absolutely beautiful, and
we're going to work hard to
make it performant, too.
ILYA GRIGORIK: It is going
to be a beautiful web.
So a couple of questions,
actually.
What is the difference between
XMP metadata and the metadata
support that's coming up?
STEPHEN KONIG: So the XMP was
sort of basic metadata.
What we're doing with the
release that's coming up now
is adding additional properties
and support, very
similar to what you find
today with JPEG.
ILYA GRIGORIK: OK.
And just maybe to clarify
the difference
between lossy and lossless.
So originally, it was basically
competing with JPEG.
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And with
lossless, we're saying you can
also now use WebP for cases
where we were using PNGs.
STEPHEN KONIG: PNG before.
Correct.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Not only that,
but we also support the alpha
channel, which is the
transparency in your images.
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And really,
up until--
so I guess GIFs also
had transparency.
But you kind of had
this weird choice.
For photos, I'm going to use a
JPEG, for lossless, I need to
use PNG, but if I want
animation, I need to use GIF.
And now, at least in theory, we
should be able to get all
of these capabilities in one.
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
And I think the challenge there,
too, is that each of
those different formats
introduces its
own pluses and minuses.
GIF and JPEG behave very
differently from an artifact
perspective.
And so it sort of required the
web developer to be aware of
all those things and understand
what are the
implications of using this
format over that format?
With WebP, you get one common
characteristic set of
properties.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So at least in
theory in the long term, as a
person who's authoring this
content, as a designer, for
example, it actually it makes
my job a lot simpler.
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
ILYA GRIGORIK: I just
save it as--
I'll probably still need some
toggles to say, this is the
use case I want you to
optimize it for.
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Or does the
encoder actually figure that
out by itself?
STEPHEN KONIG: So we certainly
have a variety of knobs and
switches you can tune
on the encoder.
I think you still need to
understand whether you're
targeting a lossless or lossy
kind of use case, and you need
to look at quality levels
depending on the use case you
have if you're doing lossy.
But definitely, the case that
you're using one image encoder
with a common set of
characteristics I
think helps a lot.
ILYA GRIGORIK: OK, awesome.
STEPHEN KONIG: So
some results.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So these are
studies that were done back in
2008, or have these--
STEPHEN KONIG: So these are
actually studies that we did
in 2011 and 2012.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Sorry,
'11, yes.
STEPHEN KONIG: 2011-2012.
We didn't have WebP in 2008.
So we've done a bunch of studies
and analyses to do
comparisons between WebP
versus JPEG and PNG.
So on the left, what
you see is a
comparison of WebP to PNG.
So basically, this chart is a
representation of the ratio of
the WebP file size to
the PNG file size.
So the one is PNG, obviously,
it's just a ratio of one.
And then for WebP, we have two
versions of that, one with
alpha and one with lossless.
And obviously, what you see
there is that for almost all
images, the WebP is
significantly
smaller than PNG.
There are a handful of cases,
less than 2%, where it's
slightly higher than one.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So that's
this peak right here?
STEPHEN KONIG: That's that
little peak right there.
But overall, across, in this
case, 1,000 images, 98% of
them were smaller, and in most
cases by a significant
degree, than PNG.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So it seems like,
especially for lossy
with alpha, if I look at, half
of the distribution here, it's
significantly less,
like 80%, 90%.
STEPHEN KONIG: You're
looking at
between 70% and 80% smaller.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Which is actually
representative of
kind of the larger number that
we saw, which is for certain
images, with alpha channel and
PNGs, we can get on average,
70% to 80% improvement
in byte size.
STEPHEN KONIG: Yep.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Which is huge.
STEPHEN KONIG: Which
is phenomenal.
And then on the right,
we did a comparison
between WebP and JPEG.
And there you see, in this
case, we're looking at
different levels of JPEG
quality, so all the way from
about 25 all the way
up to 90, and the
differences in file size.
So the red is JPEG.
But what you see there is that
again, consistently, WebP is
smaller for each
quality level.
But what you notice on the right
hand tail of that graph,
JPEG spikes up once you get
above quality about 75,
whereas WebP has a much more
static increase in file size.
So what that really tells you
is that as you get higher
quality images--
which hearkens back to what
we were discussing
before about hiDPI--
the gains you're getting from
WebP become even more
significant.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So I think it's worth pointing
out that it's a non-linear
relationship between quality
and file size.
You get the most benefit on the
high quality, and then it
kind of decays, if
you will, or the
gains actually decrease.
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So if nothing
else, going from a JPEG or
WebP from quality 100 to 90 is
going to give you more benefit
than going lower.
You should consider going lower,
but you're not going to
get as much.
STEPHEN KONIG: Yeah, you get
diminishing returns as you go
lower quickly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I think
that's a point
worth pointing out.
And maybe just one more thing.
So coming back to these tails,
right before the show we were
talking about-- so one of the
cases where this could happen,
because if you're curious, why
would WebP ever be bigger--
is actually for very small
images where the actual
container of WebP file is larger
than the image itself.
We're talking about one
by one pixels and
silly things like that.
STEPHEN KONIG: Exactly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: If you're serving
one by one pixels in
hiDPI, keep serving
them as GIFs.
STEPHEN KONIG: That's right.
ILYA GRIGORIK: For everything
else, use WebP.
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So another topic
that comes up frequently
is, great, WebP is smaller, but
I hear that it takes a lot
more time to compress
and decompress.
STEPHEN KONIG: Yep, it does.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And
that is true.
There's no free lunch.
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
ILYA GRIGORIK: More or fewer
bytes means we need to spend
more CPU cycles.
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So how big is
that difference, and does it
affect my web pages,
the loading
times and all the rest?
STEPHEN KONIG: That's
a good question.
So you're absolutely right.
The reason we get smaller file
sizes from WebP is because we
spend more time doing
the encoding work.
And so what we typically see
on average is that on the
encode side, it takes about 10
times as long to encode an
image in WebP as it
does in JPEG.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So that's
with the current--
STEPHEN KONIG: With
the current.
ILYA GRIGORIK: I think
it's a number that
actually improved, right?
STEPHEN KONIG: It
has improved.
It has improved steadily as
we've been developing the
encoder and the format,
and we expect it
to continue to improve.
We will never get to one to
one, even two to one.
2x is probably ambitious, but
we think we can certainly
bring this down more into
the range of 5x.
On the decoding side, we're
about 1.4, 1.5 times slower
than JPEG to decode an image.
But as you note here, one of
the things we see is that
consistently, the bandwidth
savings more than make up for
the increase in decoding time
on the client side.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So I guess there's a couple
points to make here.
So first of all, these
numbers are
decoding on the CPU, right?
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So there's
hardware out there that will
do hardware acceleration, for
example, for JPEG decodes.
Nothing stops hardware from
being developed for the same
thing for WebP.
STEPHEN KONIG: Absolutely not.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So it's a
question of adoption.
It's the chicken and the egg.
STEPHEN KONIG: It is.
ILYA GRIGORIK: The more people
deploy WebP, the more
incentive there is for device
manufacturers and chip makers
to actually make those
really fast.
And once they put it on silicon,
this thing's going to
be really fast.
STEPHEN KONIG: It's
going to scream.
Absolutely.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So there's
nothing that
stops that moving forward.
So there's one case here
that I think it's
interesting to point out.
So it does take a lot more
time to encode images.
So if I have a service which is
generating a lot of dynamic
images and I put Google Maps
here as a good example, right?
STEPHEN KONIG: Great example.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Generates
a lot of dynamic
tiles, customized tiles.
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
So the important thing to note
about the encoding time is
that that's a cost you're going
to spend once, versus
the bandwidth savings you're
going to recoup on every
single request.
So in most cases, you're dealing
with static images and
so to take a little bit extra
time to encode your images
once is a cost that's
easy to pay for.
There are cases, though, if
you're generating images
dynamically, and Maps is
an example of that.
They don't have static
map tile images.
They generate those on the fly
based on your request.
Where that cost can be pretty
significant and can be a
barrier to adoption.
So we think for the vast
majority of use cases out
there where you have static
content, WebP is a perfect
choice, but if you are doing
something a little more
unique, you do have
to factor that in.
ILYA GRIGORIK: As all things
performance, the answer is
always measure it.
So actually, in Chrome Dev
Tools, we've recently added
support or in a Timeline Panel,
you can actually now
see the JPEG and I think WebP
decoding times within there.
So previously, that was
not available so
you didn't even know.
And sometimes you'd
be surprised.
Decoding a large image can take
on the order of tens of
milliseconds.
So you can actually measure this
on your application and
figure out if this is indeed
a problem for you.
So we have actually a great
study which addresses this.
But before we get there, I think
you made a very, very
important point, which is it is
absolutely true that your
mobile device may need more CPU
cycles to decode a WebP
image versus a JPEG, which
that's slower.
That's objectively slower.
We can show that.
But the fact that you ship fewer
bytes and the image is
available to decode quicker on
the device actually outweighs
the benefits.
And in fact, for a lot
of people, data
compression is a big deal.
Data is literally expensive for
a lot of people, right?
And that is a huge, huge win.
STEPHEN KONIG: Especially in
emerging markets in areas
where infrastructure is not
quite as built out, that's a
huge issue for a
lot of people.
And so that's definitely
something to be aware of.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Exactly.
So this is an awesome case study
that the eBay guys did,
actually just recently, I think
a couple of weeks ago or
last week even, where they
looked at a number of
suggestions for, how do
we optimize images.
And one of the things they
considered was WebP.
So they set up this test where
they basically had just 50
images on one page, and they
had JPEGs and WebPs.
And then they used WebPagetest
to show how the
page is being rendered.
So this graph on the left here
actually shows you the visual
rendering progress.
And you can see that WebP
actually beats JPEG across the
board such that the images are
actually visible quicker.
So let me actually switch
to this view.
And if you guys are not familiar
with WebPagetest, I
would definitely encourage
you to play with it.
So let's go to the beginning.
Basically, we're seeing a
100-milisecond frame by frame,
as the browser renders it.
So we start loading images.
About a half second in, we start
rendering something.
And so far, it looks like it's
they're competitive,
both WebP and JPEG.
But you scroll a little bit
further, like 200 milliseconds
later, and you can see that a
whole bunch of WebP images
have fully loaded, more getting
pulled in, et cetera.
That's what this graph
here is showing you.
Yes, you spent more CPU time,
but the actual time to glass,
if you will, pixels visible on
the screen for WebP is better
because we're transferring
fewer bytes.
STEPHEN KONIG: Exactly.
And I think it's important
to note there that what's
important to be able to measure
is what the end user
perception as.
End users don't care about how
much time is taken up in CPU
versus how much time is taken
up transmitting bytes.
What they care about is, how
fast does this thing load, and
how fast can I see it?
And that's where WebP clearly,
in this example, shines.
Even though we're spending a
little more time on one part
of the process, we're spending
far less in another and the
net effect is definitely
positive.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So hopefully by
shipping fewer bytes and
making the decoding faster in
the future, especially if we
can offload it to the
hardware, it's a
win across the board.
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I definitely
encourage you guys.
I'll share the slides after or
just go to eBay tech blog--
I think it's still one of their
top posts, and look
through this example.
So where are we in terms
of adoption?
STEPHEN KONIG: So we're
seeing really
good progress on adoption.
Keeping in mind that we started
this a little over two
years ago with nothing,
I think we're
making really good progress.
So on mobile, I think we have
a really great story across
Android and iOS.
So Android supports
WebP today.
We added lossy support in Ice
Cream Sandwich release, and
then lossless has been
added in Jelly Bean.
In addition with iOS, we have
libraries available.
So if you're building a native
app for iOS, you can take
advantage of WebP in
your native app.
On the desktop side, Chrome and
Opera both support WebP.
And then for IE, Safari, and
Firefox, we're working with
them and we hope to get to
support it natively in the
near future.
But in the meantime, there
are solutions available.
So for IE, you can use Chrome
Frame or JavaScript, and then
Safari, either a plug-in
or JavaScript.
And then Firefox, we've
submitted a patch to Mozilla.
We continue to discuss
with them about
adding support for WebP.
I think they're receptive
to it.
They're sort of waiting for
indications of further
adoption on the community,
which we're making great
progress on.
So I'm hopeful we'll see that
adopted natively there in the
near future.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So I think an important point
to make here is something we
were talking about with the WebP
team, which is for the
last two years, you guys have
been focused on developing the
format first and foremost,
right?
It's been basically engineers
heads down, like we need these
features to meet
these criteria.
STEPHEN KONIG: Exactly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And although we
have built some tooling and
infrastructure, that wasn't
the number one priority.
Basically, we needed to get the
format to a place where it
fulfilled its role, right?
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And I think we've
kind of arrived at that
by the end of 2012.
STEPHEN KONIG: I think we
exactly have, and that's a
great way to characterize it.
The initial years of WebP were
really focused on building out
the feature set and making sure
that we had something
that was a good replacement
option for these different
image formats.
We've done that work now, and
so really the focus for us
this year is pushing hard on
adoption and optimization.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So it sounds like there's a new
release coming, literally
maybe a couple weeks away.
STEPHEN KONIG: A week to two.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Fingers
crossed.
And following that, I'm hoping
that we'll actually invest
into more of the infrastructure,
the tooling,
and everything to make authoring
WebP easier,
employing it easier.
STEPHEN KONIG: Exactly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So we have, I
guess, a couple of points to
make here as well.
We'll talk about tooling
in a second.
But Android and iOS,
ready to go.
In fact, it's actually probably
easier to deploy WebP
today on native platforms, on
Android and iOS, than it is on
the web to some degree, although
it's still definitely
doable on the web, and we will
talk about how to do that.
There is kind of a crazy
plug-in in JavaScript.
So we talked about
slower decoding.
So in fact, you can pull in this
JavaScript snippet which
will do WebP decoding
on the client.
So if you absolutely must have a
fall back for a browser that
does not understand WebP,
you can always use that.
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
And I think that's an option
that even if Microsoft
tomorrow decides to support
WebP, that's probably going to
be in IE 11.
And so for some long period of
time, you're going to have all
these older IE versions
that don't.
And so even when we get to
native support across all
these different browsers, as a
web developer, you still have
to be conscious of the fact
there are going to be users on
older browsers that can't
support WebP, and so you do
need a fallback option.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And maybe the
last point to make here is
Opera has been supporting this
for a long time because
they've actually been
using WebP.
So if you guys are familiar with
the Opera Turbo browser,
which does content optimization,
in fact, one of
the main things it does
is optimize images.
And by optimize images, I mean
transcode everything to WebP.
And that gives you huge savings,
which is why Opera
Turbo is such a great browser
for a lot of people.
Bandwidth is expensive.
WebP helps.
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And then on the
Firefox side, I've been
following the conversation
there and
it seems very promising.
I think we're going to see
something happen in 2013,
especially as we focus
more on adoption.
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
I think that's really the key
thing that they've asked for,
and I think we're going
to deliver that.
As I said, they've been
very receptive
to it, so I'm hopeful.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So speaking
of adoption, Google.
WebP.
Where are we?
Are we dog fooding?
STEPHEN KONIG: Eating our own
dog food, as it were.
Yes, we are.
So as we talked about adoption,
one of the things
that we've really been gearing
up over the past couple
months-- and you'll see us
making a lot of progress on
this throughout the
rest of this year
and into early next--
is adopting WebP across
all Google properties.
So we have it adopted across a
number today, and in fact,
Chrome Web Store launched not
too long ago with WebP Images.
There's a great blog post out
on the Chromium blog about
some of the results that
we saw from that.
But literally, we're saving
many terabytes per day of
bytes by using WebP over JPEG.
We were able to cut the page
load time by about a third, so
it was a huge win for
that team and makes
a great case study.
Across the rest of Google, we
have support today in Gmail,
Drive, and Docs, Picasa.
G+ supports it.
If you upload WebP, you'll
get WebP back.
And then we're going to be
launching the Google Play
Magazines Reader soon.
That's going to support WebP.
So there's a number of things
that are supporting it.
And we're working actively with
a bunch of other teams.
So for example, we're working
with Image Search and doing an
evaluation and experiment
right now.
As you can imagine, it's a
pretty heavily used production
service so you don't
just flip a switch.
We have to go through a whole
process of validating that
everything's going to work well,
but we're working very
well with that team, and I think
you'll see that rolling
out later this year.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So it sounds like
in a year's time, if we
were to have a 2014 episode of
this, looking back, I think
we'll look back on all the
Google properties and we'll
say, yes, all of them
support WebP.
Or at least that is our goal, or
the goal for the team, and
we're working with
all of them.
STEPHEN KONIG: We're
working hard.
And so far, we're seeing great
results across the board.
ILYA GRIGORIK: I think every
single team that has deployed
it always has a case study for
us, which is we either saved a
ton of bandwidth, or we
decreased page load time.
Usually it's both because
they go hand in hand.
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
ILYA GRIGORIK: That's awesome.
And I guess it's also worth
pointing out that there's
actually quite a few third
party services and sites
outside of Google that
are using WebP today.
So one example that I'm most
familiar with is, of course,
the PageSpeed products.
So PageSpeed Service and the
open source projects, the Mod
PageSpeed and NginX PageSpeed
will actually optimize your
images for you if you
install it in your
Apache or NginX server.
And we have over 300,000 sites
that are using these products.
So the users to those sites
are actually getting WebP
files, and we'll talk about
how that's actually
done under the hood.
So that's open source, and
there are also commercial
vendors like Torbit and
EdgeCast, so commercial CDNs,
which will do this WebP
optimization for you as well.
So there's growing adoption
for this thing.
And I think it very much
goes into the general
offering of any CDN.
They want to optimize the
web for their customers.
And optimizing images, as we
saw, 70% of the bytes, is the
number one area.
So I think we're going to see
more and more of this.
And I think automation is
actually one of the easiest
ways to get there, which is why
if you haven't looked at
something like PageSpeed or
EdgeCast or one of these
products, definitely
check it out.
So let's talk about tooling
and deployment, right?
Great.
Format's awesome.
I've got a whole lot
of JPEGs and PNGs.
How does one go about
creating WebPs?
STEPHEN KONIG: Well, the fastest
[INAUDIBLE] way to do
it is to download the WebP
libraries, and you just run a
command line and basically
give it a whole bunch of
source images and some parameter
options, and it's
going to spit out
WebP for you.
So that's the quick and
dirty way to do it.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So that's the C
WebP, so the encoder, I guess.
And if I just want to
run this on, like, I
have a folder of files.
Do I need to worry about
a whole bunch of knobs?
Do you provide sane defaults?
Basically, what should
I be considering?
STEPHEN KONIG: We definitely
provide sane defaults.
If you want to just run it
blindly on a bunch of images
you have in a folder, you're
more than welcome to do that.
It's definitely the case that if
you want to dive and tweak
and adjust things, you're
welcome do that, too.
But we try to make it
as easy as possible.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So there's
actually a couple of tools to
experiment with these files.
And maybe one thing worth
calling out is for example,
JPEGs have their own artifacts
when you compress them.
You get funny behaviors or
funny look in the image.
WebP is a different compression
format, which
means that you're going to get
slightly different artifacts,
and those could work in your
favor or against you.
So it's probably worth
experimenting in a little bit
and seeing what is the
quality that, for
example, I should be using?
What is acceptable?
STEPHEN KONIG: Definitely.
Well, it's one of the things
you want to look at because
obviously, with lower quality,
you get smaller file sizes.
So as you're trying to improve
speed, that's a knob you can
tweak that will definitely
have an impact.
But you're right.
As you lower the quality,
you're going to get more
compression artifacts.
And the kinds of artifacts you
see between JPEG and WebP are
different, especially as you get
into lower quality levels.
So you do need to do visual
comparison at that level to
understand, am I comfortable
with the kinds of artifacts
I'm seeing in these images?
ILYA GRIGORIK: So that's
something to experiment with.
And I guess the one link--
I put a couple of examples here
of the different plug-ins
that you can install, for
example, the WebP Codec for
Windows, which was developed
by you guys, right?
Which means you can just view
your WebP files natively
within Explorer and
all the rest.
There's Photoshop plug-ins.
But first and foremost,
actually, the WebP page on
Wikipedia has a fairly extensive
list of all the
tools that support it.
So if you're not sure, go there
and just search for
whatever tool you're using.
So that's a good tip.
And then the other thing is if
you go on GitHub and just
search for WebP, you'll
actually find language
bindings for virtually every
major platform that I've
looked for, at least.
So if you have a build step or
some sort of automation, you
can pull that in, and you can
actually automate this
entirely on the back end such
that you don't even have to
worry about it, which
is great.
And then kind of a fun tool that
popped up just recently,
so IMG2WebP.net.
So this is not something that
you should use for like, I'm
going to convert all my
images using this.
But if you're just curious and
without downloading the WebP
libraries or what have you, you
just want to play with it,
this is a good tool.
So I'll show you an example.
I have an image file here,
so just a photo which
I saved as a PNG.
This is my lossless
lossy format.
Beautiful image.
I'm just going to grab it and
drag it into this page.
And it is actually doing
the optimization.
So it actually picked a bunch
of defaults for me.
You can actually click on Band
Settings and play with the
different filters.
So it gives you this
.WebP file.
Let's open that.
And that looks the same,
so that's good.
And what I want to see
is the file size.
So the file size is 42 kilobytes
for this file.
Let's go back to the original.
837.
That's a bit of a
a difference.
STEPHEN KONIG: It's a
bit of a difference.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So this is an
example of both picking the
right format for the file, and
also having a format that
compresses well.
STEPHEN KONIG: Exactly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I'm sure if we
compared a JPEG version to
WebP, it wouldn't be as dramatic
of a difference, but
nonetheless, WebP would give
you a nice byte savings.
So unfortunately, this is a very
common pattern, people
saving what should be a JPEG,
or ideally WebP, as a PNG.
STEPHEN KONIG: Yes,
it happens a lot.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So let's
talk a little bit
about Android and iOS.
We're not going to go into
too much detail.
As I said, I'm going to share
the slides later.
So this is more as
a reference.
I just wanted to show that it's
actually very simple if
you're writing a native
app to integrate WebP.
So we mentioned that Android 4.0
ships natively with WebP
support, so you load
the library and
you decode the image.
Is just a bitmap.
And that's it.
That's effectively all
there is to it.
It's identical to
anything else.
One thing that's worth
mentioning is we ship native
support in 4.0 plus, but there's
a great project on
GitHub where somebody did a back
port, so for the older
versions of Android.
So you can pull that
in if you need to.
And there's a lot older Android
devices out there,
unfortunately, so that's
a handy thing to have.
And then for iOS, same thing.
You guys actually provide
the iOS framework.
STEPHEN KONIG: We do.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So if you
download the library, I guess,
you can actually compile
it, and you get the
WebP.framework, which you can
include in your iOS project
and then go from there.
And if you look at the code,
it's effectively the same
thing as we saw previously.
There's a great tutorial
on this.
If you just search for
WebP iOS, there's a
couple great write ups.
And likewise, there is a really
nice project sitting on
GitHub, which is actually a
pre-built, or pre-made iOS app
which includes WebP.
So you can just download that,
build it, run it, see how it
works, and adjust it as you
need it kind of thing.
So that's the native side.
I'm going to claim that that
one is actually easier.
STEPHEN KONIG: It is today.
You're right.
ILYA GRIGORIK: WebP on the
web is a little bit more
complicated, but it's
still doable.
So there's a couple different
strategies basically.
There is client side and server
side, and there are
cons and pros to each
one, unfortunately.
And ideally, you probably need
both to make them work well.
So let's work through
an example.
We have an awesome WebP file
which we want to serve, and
basically, the difference here
is that some user agents-- for
example, Internet Explorer--
does not natively
understand WebP.
If the user has Chrome
Frame installed,
they will render WebP.
But if they don't, they
can't do that.
Same thing for Firefox.
So basically, depending on which
browser comes to our
page or loads an image, we need
to decide which image
we're going to serve,
a JPEG or a WebP.
So this in itself actually
creates another concern for
some people, which is I also
need to duplicate my storage.
I need to have both files,
which is true.
But we find, at least in all of
our case studies at Google,
that this is definitely a
worthwhile investment because
it gives such a better
experience to the user.
STEPHEN KONIG: Correct.
And I think the thing I'd point
out on that is it's a
question of who should be paying
the cost and where is
that best paid for?
And I would argue that it's
better paid for on the part of
the web developer and
the site author.
It's better for them to pay for
a little bit more storage
and some more memory for the
cache than it is to ask every
single user who hits your
page to spend more time
downloading, and potentially
more money on bandwidth if
they're on mobile.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Exactly.
And of course, as the adoption
grows, this also becomes less
of a problem.
So for example, for client side
detection, Modernizer
actually has a test for WebP.
So if you have your client side
code, you can actually
just say, Modernizer.webp, and
then if it's enabled, you can
schedule an image download
that way.
And if the test fails, you can
actually fall back even to the
JavaScript include, or you
can schedule your JPEGs.
So either one works.
And the benefits of
this is it'll
work across all browsers.
This code will run in Chrome
just as well as in IE and
everything else.
The trouble with this is because
in this example here
I'm actually creating the image
tag via JavaScript, it
means that I need to download
the HTML, download this
JavaScript, execute JavaScript,
and only then will
the image be scheduled, whereas
the browsers today are
very, very good at scheduling
things as quickly
as possible up front.
So that's kind of the trade
off that we have here.
So that's one thing
to keep in mind.
It's one strategy.
The other is to do server side
detection, which basically
means that a request comes into
your web server and your
web server looks at the user
agent header that your browser
sends and it says, hey,
this is Chrome.
Chrome indeed supports WebP, so
I'm going to serve you this
version of the file, which
actually has .webp in it.
And this is actually what
PageSpeed and Torbit and other
products do.
They do this server side
detection, and they actually
serve different HTML files,
which doesn't incur any of the
JavaScript cost, but
it has a slightly
different negative side.
Which is because the file itself
is different between
browsers, we need to declare it
as cache control private,
which means that this file can
still be cached by the client
for however long you
specify, but it is
private to this client.
You can't share this file
between all the browsers,
which may or may not be an issue
depending on how your
cache or CDN strategy works.
So in PageSpeed, we actually
mark the base HTML file as
cache control private, which
means it's cached by the
client but not by the
intermediate cache, but then
all of the images are cached
for a year, which is where
most of your cost is.
Because if we go back to that
very first slide that I have,
HTML is like--
there's 40 kilobytes of it, and
then there's 800 kilobytes
of the rest.
So the 800 kilobytes
are cached.
So pros and cons once again.
Take a look at Mod PageSpeed
or how it does it under the
hood, or you can write this
function yourself.
It's actually pretty simple.
Basically you're saying,
if user agent is
Chrome or Opera, great.
Serve WebP.
So I think that's basically
us at the end.
So we have a couple
of questions.
But before we get to the
questions, you mentioned some
of the things that
are coming ahead.
What can we expect in 2013?
STEPHEN KONIG: I think by and
large, what you're going to
see in 2013 is lots of
progress on adoption.
We've talked about that.
And as we make more progress
on that, we're going to be
shouting from the rooftops
about all the great case
studies that we're confident
we'll see, and some of the
data that we're starting to
see already working with a
bunch of internal
Google teams.
We're working with one
now that does a lot
of serving of photos.
ILYA GRIGORIK: I wonder
who that could be.
STEPHEN KONIG: I don't know.
I can't imagine who
it might be.
But in that case, we're seeing
upwards of 50% to 60%
reduction in image sizes, so
you can imagine the kind of
impact that has on the
user experience.
So we're excited about that.
We'll hopefully launch
that very soon.
You'll see many more
examples like that.
And then alongside that, we're
going to continue to focus on
optimization and trying to bring
that encode and decode
time down even further.
But you know, we're at a point
today, we're ready to really
push the gas pedal and make some
great progress with WebP.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Awesome.
OK, so maybe one thing to point
out before we head to
questions is we do have the
public WebP Discuss group
where you can ask questions,
follow up.
If we didn't cover something
here or we're not going to get
to your question, then
just head there
and drop us a question.
So let's see.
So we talked about the adoption
of WebP from other
vendors, right?
So we're working with
Firefox, there are
plug-ins for other browsers.
There are ways you can basically
provide this
functionality in there.
And then I guess there's
user agent section
and a few other things.
So there's a great question here
about what's the current
progress of animated WebP?
So it sounds like that's
coming in weeks.
STEPHEN KONIG: We talked
about that.
That's going to be very soon.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And are there
any plans to eventually use
predictive features of VP8 to
keep animated WebP small?
STEPHEN KONIG: Good question.
It's definitely something
we're thinking about and
looking into.
There's also going to be
improvements down the road to
the VP video format, so we're
going to be taking a look at
those and seeing how
we might be able to
adopt those as well.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, OK.
What is the current process
for third party support?
We talked about that.
I'd like to see digital cameras
and phones saving high
quality photos as WebPs.
STEPHEN KONIG: Yeah,
we'd love that too.
I think it's important
understand that adoption is a
bit of a progression.
So today, if we go talk to a
camera manufacturer, they're
going to say, well, why should
I spit out WebP images from
the camera?
I can't upload those
a lot of places.
So we have to sort of work this
in a stepwise manner.
And so getting WebP adopted
across the web will make it a
lot easier for us to go to
consumer electronic device
manufacturers--
camera makers, phones,
et cetera--
and say, you really should store
this natively in WebP.
And the story there
is the same.
It's wow, for the same compact
SD card that I have in my
camera, I get essentially one
and a half or two times as
many images.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So just to
reiterate the example you just
gave, this one shall be unnamed
product, Android
product, that serves a lot of
photos, you grab the photo off
your camera-- probably a JPEG,
probably a couple megabytes.
They then transcode it to WebP
and upload the WebP because
it's so much more efficient.
STEPHEN KONIG: That would
be the way to do it.
Absolutely.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So yeah, if the
camera saved it directly as
WebP, that would be great.
STEPHEN KONIG: Even better.
ILYA GRIGORIK: But it'll
probably take some time before
we get there.
STEPHEN KONIG: Yep.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So WebP can be
a more efficient compression
algorithm than JPEG
and PNG but it
uses more CPU resources.
Please keep that in mind.
Yep.
So that's a legitimate point,
and measure it.
We actually have the tools now
in Chrome Dev Tools, so take a
look at that.
And you saw the eBay example.
So there's bandwidth costs and
there's CPU costs, and it
really depends on your
application.
I think for a majority,
bandwidth is far more important.
MALE SPEAKER: Ilya, we actually
had a fun question
from YouTube.
Josh was asking, because
everyone's excited about
Project Glass.
He wants to know if Project
Glass is going to save in WebP
automatically to save on
mobile data usage.
What's your insight into that,
and are you going to break
something confidential?
STEPHEN KONIG: As soon as I can
start dog fooding a Glass
device, I will make sure that's
the first feature we
put in there.
How is that?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Fair enough.
So Francois actually asked a
great question, which is
Chrome itself, internally, for
all the images and Dev Tools
and all the rest uses PNG.
I guess not a question, it's
more of a comment.
Why aren't we using WebP?
STEPHEN KONIG: We should
be, and we're
going to fixing that.
Absolutely.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And actually,
Addy replied to that and said,
yes, open a bug about this.
We should fix it.
So we're on it.
STEPHEN KONIG: In fact, I opened
a bug about this not
too long ago, so we'll
get it fixed.
ILYA GRIGORIK: JNG could have
been used to produce JPEG
images with Alpha Channel.
Not actually familiar with that
format, but I think maybe
the point here to make is I said
WebP, kind of one to rule
them all, but I actually believe
that we need many
different image formats
on the web.
We have this artificial
limit of three today
for whatever reason.
We've all somehow agreed that
that's all we need.
Thou shalt use a GIF, a PNG,
and a JPEG, and there's no
reason for it.
We could optimize things
much better.
STEPHEN KONIG: Exactly.
And we see this sometimes when
we go out and talk to folks
about adoption.
They say, well, what about
this format or
what about that format?
And our view is that there's
room on the web for lots of
different formats, and
ultimately, they all should
stand on their own and
prove themselves.
We don't view it as an exclusion
to other options.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So is there any
way to use WebP in Android
less than 4x?
Yes.
So there's that backport, and
I'll share the slides later so
you can find the link to it.
Wouldn't just using a PNG file
be faster than converting WebP
with a plug-in?
I am not sure what this
is actually asking.
STEPHEN KONIG: Well,
I guess it depends.
If you're using, so say Safari
with a plug-in--
ILYA GRIGORIK: Oh, I mean
for browsers that
don't support it.
STEPHEN KONIG: For browsers
that don't support it.
Potentially.
I think again, you have to
measure that in terms of what
is the bandwidth savings from
the smaller file size.
Obviously, plug-ins aren't
perfect either because they
introduce a little bit of user
friction into the experience,
and the user has to install
the plug-in and so on.
So that's something to
bear in mind as well.
ILYA GRIGORIK: OK.
So Aaron Peters here.
So if you serve static images
off a CDN and you want to
support all the usual browsers,
including all of the
IEs and Firefox browsers that
don't support WebP, then how
to get WebP served off the
CDN to Chrome and Opera?
So this is a great question,
and I think this actually
boils down to support
at the CDN level at
the edge for WebP.
So as an example, PageSpeed
Service, which is the Google
hosted PageSpeed libraries, we
actually do the user agent
detection at the Edge
on our Edge servers.
And actually, that's the same
strategy that EdgeCast uses.
So EdgeCast actually uses
PageSpeed open source
libraries under the hood, they
deploy it at the Edge, they
run this user agent detection,
and then they serve the
correct file.
So unfortunately, that means
that the CDN itself has to
support WebP, but I think from
my conversations with a lot of
the major CDNs out there, it's
definitely something that
everybody's considering just
because the mobile web is
shooting through the roof.
Pages are getting bigger.
You saw the number of
bytes on the wire.
So they're all looking at this
in some way or another.
So I think we're going
to get there.
And that's not to say that
user agent is the
only way to do it.
I think there are better ways.
In fact, we've been talking
with the Chrome team about
fixing some of the accept
headers and making this easier
such that you don't have to
write these crazy user agent
detection functions.
Instead, you should be able to
look at the accept header and
it should say, yes, I really
do support WebP.
Give me a WebP file.
STEPHEN KONIG: Yeah.
That's a great solution in
the long term, and I
think we'll get there.
The advantage to that is you
don't have these hard coded
rules about user agents and
which ones support WebP,
because as more support them,
then you have to go change
that logic.
Whereas if you just look at the
accept header, if a new
browser comes along it
supports WebP, great.
You're going to serve
WebP to it.
No change needed.
So we'll get there.
MALE SPEAKER: So Ilya,
back on YouTube.
Zachary asks about encryption.
Would it be possible to encrypt
WebP images so nobody
can intercept them, two
examples being profile
pictures or personal things?
ILYA GRIGORIK: So the short
answer is yes, you can deliver
them over SSL, and I think
that's all there is to it.
STEPHEN KONIG: I think
that's probably the
best way to do it.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Unless you guys
are working to on a secret new
feature for--
STEPHEN KONIG: We are not
planning on doing any secret
new compression algorithms.
No.
ILYA GRIGORIK: OK.
Yes, so I think that one's
actually pretty simple.
SSL, that's the answer there.
Compared to JPEG Mini--
are you familiar with JPEG
Mini by any chance?
STEPHEN KONIG: A little bit.
Again, I would just say, as a
site author, I think you need
to look at different
options and decide
what's best for you.
I think we're very confident in
how WebP stacks up against
alternative formats, but if you
find JPEG Mini is a good
choice, then that's fine.
We think WebP offers a much
better alternative for the
vast majority of use cases
that are out there today.
ILYA GRIGORIK: At the end the
day, make the web fast.
If you make it faster,
we're happy.
If you use WebP, great.
If you find some other magic
bullet, awesome.
As long as it's faster.
I guess a comment from Max.
The fire didn't look realistic
in that WebP
version versus PNG.
So maybe, I don't know.
But I think this actually points
out an important point.
It's all about your own
decision making
and your art direction.
So you need to find the
right quality level.
I'm not even sure what
the default was.
STEPHEN KONIG: There were
defaults that were set on
there that you probably
needed to tweak.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So don't just
look at, here's an image,
here's an output from
some tool I got.
There's a whole bunch of knobs,
and you can tweak those
knobs and optimize
for your case.
So if you absolutely must have
a certain quality and detail
in your images, we give
you those knobs.
If anything, there's
too many knobs.
I wrote a batch script
called Script WebP.
It converts PNG and JPEG files
to WebP using cwebp using
simple drag and drop.
Awesome.
STEPHEN KONIG: That's great.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So definitely
check that out.
What is the adoption rate of
WebP format on internet pages?
So I shared some data previously
about the PageSpeed
server, so that's the one that
I'm most familiar with.
There's over 300 sites using
those products today, and they
are serving WebP to clients
that support it.
So that's the ones I know of.
There are also commercial
vendors that
provide this service.
So there's a lot of sites,
actually, that are using it.
And as we said, we're going to
see a lot more Google sites
and third party.
STEPHEN KONIG: And third
party sites.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Hopes
for PictureTag.
So the PictureTag conversation,
I think, is
orthogonal to this.
PictureTag has a lot more other
things going for it, and
I hope that it will
actually come.
I think it's something
that we need.
It's a question of, can we
actually pick some--
there are many things that
PictureTag could be, and we
may need to cut some corners and
cut out some use cases to
actually make it happen.
Do we get improvement for
black and white images?
STEPHEN KONIG: I believe so.
There's no reason
why we wouldn't.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Will Google
Drive and Android
support WebP soon?
STEPHEN KONIG: Yes, hopefully.
We will make sure it does.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So it sounds
like you guys are working.
So thanks for your answer, but
UA detection on the Edge that
is part of the CDNs, expensive,
dynamic content
acceleration products.
Most sites serve HTML off their
own servers and static
off the CDN.
So I guess you need to
do the UA detection.
Yes.
So for example, the strategy
that Mod PageSpeed and the
NginX PageSpeed service uses
is we generate a different
HTML file, and that file
contains different links.
So one contains links to WebP,
and the other contains a link
to, for example, JPEG.
And then those files can be just
statically linked to any
CDN and everything is fine.
So you don't need cooperation of
your CDN provider for that.
So that solution also has some
caveats, but that's what a lot
of sites have been doing today,
and it is workable.
Is the format patent free?
STEPHEN KONIG: Absolutely.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So free open
source, BSD licensed.
I think if you actually go to
the WebM project, they also
even give you schematics for
building chips, which I think
is awesome.
So I think we've answered
everything that's been here.
If you guys have more questions,
WebP Discuss, but
otherwise--
MALE SPEAKER: One last
question on YouTube.
So Josh loves this
show, by the way.
So he's asking about Android
cameras getting the ability to
convert to WebP on the fly.
If they're running Android 4.x,
maybe they can save in
Raw and WebP.
STEPHEN KONIG: Yeah, that's
certainly something I think we
will see over time.
It gets back to the challenge
today would be if you spit
them out as WebP, it would
restrict where you could
upload those photos today.
So as we get more adoption on
sites that support WebP
uploads, then something like
what you're describing makes a
lot of sense, and I think we
will see that over time.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So if
you're a service--
if you run the service to where
you're uploading and you
support WebP, and let's say-- so
this actually could work, I
think both for native
and web apps.
So for native, you request
your camera, you grab the
bytes, and then you can--
STEPHEN KONIG: Convert them.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Convert that
into WebP and upload it to
your service.
You can do the same
thing on the web
today, actually, right?
You have access to the camera
API, you get your basically
buffer, you convert that to WebP
and send that back up.
So if you're trying to upload
WebP to, I don't know, Flickr.
I've actually talked to Flickr
and we had a conversation with
them, but they don't currently
support it.
So if you just throw that
out to Flickr, they'll
say, I have no idea.
STEPHEN KONIG: I don't know
what you're giving me.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Exactly.
MALE SPEAKER: What about
OS support for WebP?
I mean, if people download it
from their browsers and they
view their images, do they need
to download the codec for
the OS as well?
ILYA GRIGORIK: That's
a good question.
So on Windows, we actually
provide a plug-in.
STEPHEN KONIG: There
is a plug-in.
And for OSX, there's a
third party plug-in
that does the same.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So
unfortunately, it's not native.
If the user just drags in the
file, they won't be able to
view it, but there are plug-ins
for both platforms.
And is there anything
for Linux?
STEPHEN KONIG: I believe so.
If you go to the Wikipedia site,
there are definitely
[INAUDIBLE].
ILYA GRIGORIK: So actually,
that's a good point.
Go to the Wikipedia
site and you can
download those plug-ins.
And I hope, as we said, we're
going to make the tooling
better in 2013.
All right, I think that's it.
Awesome.
STEPHEN KONIG: Awesome.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Thank you guys.
Thanks, Stephen.
STEPHEN KONIG: Thank you, Ilya.